hi guys if you're a fan of horror then
you have definitely heard of the game
outlast now outlast 2 demo has been out
for a while on PC however it's only just
come about on PlayStation so I got to
play it for you and I got very scared
and joy you are black Langerman a
cameraman working with your wife Lynn
the two of you are investigated with a
journalist willing to take risks and dig
deep to uncover the stories no one else
will dare touch you're following a trail
of clues that start with the seemingly
impossible murder of a pregnant woman
known as Jane Doe okay so that's like
your average name that you don't know
what the name is so you give her the
name Jane Doe the investigation has led
you miles into the Arizona desert to a
darkness so deep that no one could shed
light upon it and a corruption so
profound that going mad may be the only
sane thing to do okay that makes sense
does it
no it doesn't
Oh upside-down cross
you know I used to be really religious
when I was kid that's even scared about
so dumb
it was sucks meat glasses I'm sorry to
anyone who does its turn on night
fingers i three I don't eat it now I'm
gonna waste it to zoom wait what do they
want me to do zoom and then nobody
needed it
I wish at the end of this game you could
see all the all the fish that you took
oh I'm lost and hurt
okay I have a fanny I don't really want
to go in there anyway what's up
it's more houses anybody there
oh no this is creepy please reloaded my
batteries hello Oh Ernie oh this is
depressing but this batteries that's a
good thing
okay bye shoo try again
now then always happens in our games
it's so overdone okay
that was another house should we go in
here see what this is is there anything
in here nope
it's very dark
what the [ __ ] is there a person around
yeah over there wait are they did I see
them or did I just think I saw there's a
person
oh no wait I'm confused
why are people just standing around
what's this that a cow
should I go into these houses
I can't knock on any of these doors
okay the height I'm hiding in the bowel
they've already seen me though here my
heart is firm what am i doing
I know
but don't just opened didn't it
okay I'm exiting I don't even know why I
did that
what was the point of that this goes
away that's a nice painting
suppose it behind us I don't need to
hide anything in here for us batteries
or anything this guy is very tall he's
taller than the stove and everything I'm
not used to this I'm sure than
everything
what's that instead of a house that's in
there where do I go all batteries
should we try and down here Oh open
window nice Bank that opening okay
that's the quick escape we'll leave that
open you know there's a few hiding
places back there if we need them yeah
wish we could pick up the candle take it
with us that would make more sense I
don't know where to go oh what's through
the other door though that's lots okay
okay so far not so bad but it's just
teaching me how to move and stuff or it
isn't nothing big Oh we'd love batteries
I should probably spend
oh my god what the hell Eddie I did not
know I was going in somewhere okay let's
go in here
Oh what is this what is this oh hey
what like a hey cradle for a baby baby
cradle what I just jumped for no reason
they're all banned
okay um where do we go
that's cool
this kind of reminds me of a Bioshock
would say you would always do stuff like
this with the shadows and
who the [ __ ] why is she whispering oh
yeah what the [ __ ] oh my shadow scared
me stop it
stop
oh you're in the Wow
okay note to self if you hear a weird
voice in a well please go check it out
this is not a little girl even though it
sounds like a little girl it's not oh I
should have explored more there's more
things up there oh well stop
I don't know what's happening I'm
missing everything cuz I'm too scared to
I don't
don't waste my batteries where did my
camera go so who is this person talking
to me because she sounds like she's in
my head I'm confused
are there any batteries around here
because yes
a little jump for joy okay where should
I go
me it's too quiet I don't like it
schools at nighttime are just creepy
schools I just don't like school in
general was this someone in there huh
breathe on me what does it say hey Lin
I'm bored you come over still talking
about the 30 Years War mister come over
blah blah blah ha Habsburg phlegm up
anyway I'm not riding home with you
today because I got Journal but I'll
call you when I get home okay
sup Jess comb-overs for worst his nasal
spray totally makes me want to puke I
have to this was Jessica's
something's gonna pop out I'm ready for
this jump scare I'm ready
what nothing popped out oh I need a
batteries don't laugh at me I want to
read that what the bloody hell did
something just don't bother me I'm
confused what happens I can't see
anything oh okay I progress with Ricky
no I can't go anywhere okay let's just
run back through and then try one of
these nice hi oh my god
was I supposed to do that straight away
and I just kept something running up and
down the hallway I'm freaking idiot okay
is there a is there a battery
I need batteries only this is only the
the demo I suck no I don't want to go
back out there
screw that
guys what the hell no what do i do do I
go down there
no no no I don't hide in the locker okay
let's not go underneath this weird black
stuff okay never go to music room again
okay this is the bit I [ __ ] suck at
running like you have no why can I just
pose the door open the door get out the
freakin door
run run faster but I've got to run where
do I go go hide in the freaking barrel
hide
these are funny these are funny these
are funny
how many people are looking for me but
this sounds like more is he going
should we exit let's go no oh oh [ __ ] hi
mama mama-mama ma-ma-ma-ma-ma mom
what where am I supposed to go I don't
know
am I going completely the wrong way
probably hey I found something
I'm ill I'm ill shite thinner burn my
mama mama mama that's all I'm saying
I need to find somewhere to hide
anything sweet gases down you go
so the glasses fall that's gonna hurt
I'm sorry any males watching that stand
not really nice to watch I hope you guys
enjoyed that quick playthrough of the
outlast 2 demo
it definitely did not resist a point
Melilla ok with Zeke it definitely did
not disappoint
I was very scared and I'm looking
forward to this game it's gonna be a
good one
probably gonna livestream it for you
though so let me know what you think
about seeing this game when it comes out
have a lovely day or evening bye
you put the cassettes in the computer
and press play soit nah I was why did I
scare him that wasn't even scary